let me let me ask you about your your
view of how things have been going today
i mean there's been a lot uh in the past
several years with the riots of the
country
over george floyd i'm curious as to your
perspective
you're older than us and so you
certainly have seen way more
does it feel worse today in terms of the
political divide than it has in the past
i wouldn't say that it really feels
worse you know there's always been a
divide but people today
are more outspoken
and less uh hidden about their views
there it seems to be a more um
emboldening if you will
today like you know you see people who
used to wear um
hoods and masks
uh come out there with their uh burning
crosses and now they come out in their
regular clothes and express the same
views so they don't feel like you know
they have to hide so much anymore
because their jobs are being threatened
or whatever when did you so let's let we
can just get started with your story for
people who aren't familiar do you want
so just in in terms of the context i
want to talk about modern politics and
all this stuff and where we are now but
i think your history might lend some
understanding blood people
how did you you're famous for being the
how did you describe it the um you
inspired people to um de-radicalize the
clans members okay so to give you a
little bit of background on myself as i
said i was i'm 64 years old but i grew
up as the child of parents in the u.s
foreign service so i grew up as an
american embassy brat i i was born in 58
i began traveling around the world at
the age of six of uh of three in 1961
and uh how it works is you you get
assigned to a country for two years
you come back here to the states you're
here for a few months maybe a year and
then you're assigned to another country
abroad so my first exposure to school
was overseas i i did kindergarten first
grade third grade fifth grade seventh
grade
and all the schools i went to overseas
this is back in the 1960s
my classmates were from nigeria japan
russia czechoslovakia germany france
italy sweden anybody who had an embassy
in those particular countries all of
their kids went to the same school so
that became my baseline as to what
school was supposed to be about i had
all these colors
you guys here are too young to remember
black and white tv but you know about it
i remember black and white tv and i
remember when color tv came in it was
like wow it's like a whole new dimension
right you know you never want to see
black and white tv again you saw
something in living color
okay well every time i come back home
from overseas back to my own country the
united states it was like going from
color tv to black and white you know
because we did not have that amount of
diversity in this country in our schools
when i would come back i would either be
in all black schools or black and white
schools meaning the still segregated or
the newly integrated just because uh
brown versus the board of education
desegregated schools in 1954 it didn't
mean that integration took place
overnight it took years and years but
even in in many cases still it's not
exactly in fact the uh prince edward
county virginia
shut down they refused to integrate
schools the public schools they shut
down all public schools in prince edward
county virginia not for five days
not for five weeks not for five months
for five
years
years
okay imagine how much education is lost
in five years when you go down there
today people my age a lot of them are
basically functional illiterates because
they miss five years of their education
if you know if they were in third grade
you know they didn't go back to school
until they were in eighth grade you know
you know that kind of thing um so you
know you're dealing with that kind of
thing so look look at kids today who
have to go to school over zoom over the
last two years because of the pandemic
some some kids did better than others
but a lot of a lot of them did not do so
well over zoom because they weren't
getting that personal one-on-one
education you know well as as an aside
too i want to do real derail too much i
think we're going to start seeing
something similar because schools have
started adopting ideological practice in
their teachings
so instead of telling a kid
you know 2 plus 2 equals 4 they're
saying 2 plus equals 5.
well
in what context are we talking so you
actually had a viral trend where people
teachers were saying two plus two equals
five in what context it was that two
point four plus two point four equals
four point eight which is rounded up to
five so if you round down two point four
i don't know what kind of simplicity
mess this they were intending but it was
it was it's an issue of tribalism and
this is it's part of the polarization
the idea is
that the people on the right started
saying two plus two is four and sooner
or later the woke people are gonna say
it's not and then a point was being made
by you know left tribal people where
they're like two plus two could be five
here's how and then they say two point
two point four rounds down to two but
two point four plus two point four is
4.8 which which rounds to 5. therefore 2
plus 2 is 5. and then most people who
are
reasonable are just like
2.4 plus 2.4 is 4.8 end of story if you
want to make some weird equation that
omits information for the sake of making
your strange argument
i guess
but they're teaching kids this you also
have a lot of the critical race theory
ideology stuff in schools where the kids
are getting more of this kind of social
emotional learning as opposed to
actually learning stuff okay so let's
let's define two terms that you use just
just so that everybody's on the same
page not just us here but everybody out
here listening to us so
let's let's let's define the term woke
your definition of term woke and your
definition of the term critical race
theory
woke is typically
a reference to like a a left tribal
identifier so
it has a reference to critical race
theory critical theory critical gender
theory it encompasses these different
schools of thought
we gotta we gotta define all these
things critical race theory is um
basically the in the oh man this getting
it gets tough to actually is that a
stinkbug critical race theory is
critical theory in a racial context
critical theory is the the political
theory of the oppressed versus the
oppressors with karl marx back in the
day cr his critical theory was that the
wealthy oppress the poor the poor the
proletariat is oppressed the bourgeoisie
oppresses kimberly crenshaw wrote a book
called critical race theory which says
this doesn't take into context the race
the racial component of the united
states therefore critical race theory is
white people are dominant and they
oppress all people of color so critical
race theory has several different
subsequent schools of thought like
intersectionality that a
black woman experiences different
discrimination than a black man because
there's also sexism plus racism but the
sexism plus racism is a different
category than the sexism that a white
woman would experience so this is
another school of thought within the
realm of critical race theory critical
race praxis is the implementation of
these ideas into standardized learning
an example would be
if i were to give you a math problem i
would say a train leaves pittsburgh
traveling at 100 miles an hour a train
leaves cincinnati traveling at 75 miles
an hour they're 300 miles apart how long
blah blah blah critical race practice
gives math problems to kids like in
florida
jerome was stopped by the police 17
times in the past month harold was
stopped three times what percentage are
black people stopped by police more than
white people so what they're doing is it
is a math question
but they're injecting an ideology a
praxis of critical race assuming that
jerome is black
well
they do these things that are overtly
racist
absolutely and but it'll show a little
black character and it'll show a little
white character and then they'll they'll
do this problem and so we've started
seeing the emergence of a lot of that
what i see from this is one viral video
that went around is a kid who didn't
understand pronouns because this is
wokeness includes what is crit what is
called critical gender theory which is
boys and girls don't exist
doctors guess gender
and so there's a video of a little boy
asking uh he he's doing a pronoun
worksheet
and it says something like juan gets on
the swing which pronoun would you use
janet uses jump ropes which pronouns
would you use and you put they for all
of them and his mom goes why did you put
they for all of them and he says how am
i supposed to know if they're boys or
girls and she said didn't you notice
their names and he was like but you said
there's no boys or girls in names
and so now the kids don't understand
basic english grammar because of these
of the practice being injected in in in
our you know in the current generation
the current learning systems so
not to do well too much from what you
were saying because now we're getting
particularly verbose uh
when you talk about these schools the
first thing i think of is
at this point schools have become so
corrupt in many ways i think regardless
of whether we have them or not people
are going to become functionally
illiterate
basically when you mention functional
illiterates i thought of the kid who
didn't know how to use pronouns and
everything that
comprises that problem we're
experiencing
assuming that
that he doesn't
know that janet
is a female name or now is uh
androgynous right where janet could be a
male name or a female name like for
example my name is daryl uh for the
longest time i thought daryl was always
a male name until an actress came along
named daryl hannah that's right
well so uh so that defines wellness was
there another
another term no that was a weakness and
a critical race theory yeah okay well
there we go i think the impossible thing
about it is that everything is blended
together
and so every issue becomes into
with intersectionality the like the
reality is that if you're talking about
race you're talking race and gender are
different conversations but yeah they're
the same conversation and so it makes it
it makes it really hard to to talk about
anything because so
woke blends all of that together yeah
and it's just that's it's hard to define
because it it also means different
things to different people i think i
could define wokeness is like it's like
a faux awakening people feel like
they're having awakening right now and
but it's it's an awakening to like what
they're being told is is is real so they
just believe what they're told rather
than a real like central awakening of
like having like a reality shift
so or
you know what i mean it's not like like
an internal
struggling i mean maybe it is for them
they're probably having a similar
feeling to someone that's actually had a
spiritual awakening on a hill meditating
for 40 days but it's like a
false awakening and people are making
fun of it calling it oh they're woke
they're so awake now have you ever heard
the term red pill
red build red pilled
no it's the inverse of woke but they
basically mean the same thing okay if
you are red pill that's a reference to
the matrix you get the blue pill the red
pill the red pill wakes you up from the
illusion of reality woke means you've
awoken to what's really going on and so
they mean effectively the same thing a
great realization of the lies you've
been told
based on my understanding and i think of
fair research
red pill is a bit trolly and more
tongue-in-cheek woke is zealous and
ideological but i also think the woke
stuff is manipulative and wrong for the
most part so you know we have to have
people on here and i talk well okay so
so for example
uh when i was in high school
uh we were taught
in the textbooks i still got my
textbooks
that uh that robert uh
uh perry uh admiral perry uh discovered
the um the north pole
not true
you know uh matthew henson discovered
the north pole
admiral perry was a white guy
matthew henson was a black guy
matthew henson was admiral perry's best
friend and they went on the exploration
together okay perry got sick
and told henson to go on
henson went on and discovered the north
pole all right interesting when
uh they got back perry told everybody it
was henson they said no we can't give
him the credit and they gave the credit
to admiral perry all right admiral perry
was buried
in arlington cemetery
matthew henson was buried in a pauper's
grave
uh in the 1980s when ronald reagan was
uh was in office as president
uh there was a a bill put forth uh
coretta scott king and some other people
came to him
and
he uh passed this bill now in the
textbooks it says matthew henson
discovered the north pole now i knew
that all along because my parents told
me even though it wasn't in the textbook
all right um they exhumed matthew henson
from the pauper's grave grave and now
he's buried next to his best friend uh
admiral perry in arlington cemetery when
i was in school
uh we did not learn that this country
had internment camps for japanese
americans i didn't learn that until i
was in college and i was incredulous i
was like what are you kidding me no way
and i asked my parents they're like yeah
you know why wasn't it why wasn't it in
our textbooks because it was a it was a
dark blemish on our history it was a
shameful thing that we did in this
country
so did i become woke when i was in
college but that's not wokeness all
right so what is what so uh an example
of wokeness is saying things like all
white people are racist
all white people are not racist but
that's wokeness is not a reference to
understanding how history works so i'll
give you an example when i was a little
kid uh i was told in school christopher
columbus discovered america which is
just not true right there were already
people here but did you know that yes
because i had uh i had a mom who told me
there were already people here right and
i tell the story all the time she said
actually leif erikson came to the to the
north american continent a thousand
years before christopher columbus but
honey there were already people there
weren't there and i was like yeah and
she goes did they teach you there were
already people there and i was like yes
and she goes didn't they discover this
continent and i was like
yeah i was like then why did they tell
me that and she said they think you're
stupid but they'll tell you the truth in
college
and that was like a real
anti-authoritarian moment for me as a
kid
so was that an awakening or or awoke
so wokeness doesn't refer to learning
the truth wokeness is typical i mean
depending on who you're talking to right
if you're talking to people who are
trying to avoid the overt ideologies of
either you know extremists what any
extremist faction wokeness is typically
a pejorative term to reference someone
who says you're white so you're racist
that's considered to be woke now some
people might use woke in a more relaxed
manner like
perhaps towards the angle you're
describing it but uh based on like this
show and how we we approach things most
people who watch would probably say
they're anti-woke but they completely
agree with what you've said or would
completely agree with the idea that
native americans already were here right
the the proper way to describe it is
christopher columbus discovered
uh the bahamas
for europeans as part of the european
culture he was the first to kind of
bring that information to them but again
leif ericsson also of european descent
discovered it it didn't really make the
rounds in the european continent and
other people were already here who had
discovered the land typically typically
people do not use woke as like a badge
you know people who's even more critical
people don't no they don't they don't
and so so people who are like pro
critical race theory wouldn't
necessarily call themselves that and i
think look most people are pro
uncensored history i think that is a
common thing that we need to get on this
no
i would have to disagree with well maybe
i don't i'm i'm i don't have a statistic
in front of me but i think we all here
want well uncensored history and so it
gets complicated because
critical race theory some people are
trying to say that critical race theory
is the truth of history that's some
people's perspective other people would
agree with teaching what you just said
was omitted right but that wouldn't that
that's not
the same as critical race theory so take
a look at this image this is part of a
book called not my idea
in which grade school children are shown
the whiteness contract with a white hand
reaching out and a devil tail and goat's
feet
i think this is wrong to teach children
that white people are inherently evil
inherently oppressors or inherently
racist that all white people are racist
and this is what woke typically means
when we criticize it i think uh
we should tell people that some people
are good some people are bad and race is
not relevant to whether someone will be
a good or bad person you've got to find
out who they are within would you agree
i would agree 100 with that well the
problem is is what they're teaching kids
in school
dude we can see your pointy tail
contract binding you to whiteness you
get stolen land stolen riches special
favors whiteness gets to mess endlessly
with the lives of your friends neighbors
loved ones and fellow humans of color
sign below for the purpose of profit
land riches and favors may be revoked at
any time for any reason
showing a white hand reaching out with a
whiteness conjugate and devil's tail i
think is
particularly dangerous to be teaching
children
okay but now
so that's called critical race theory by
your definition correct yes okay but
there are also people who are calling
critical race theory
teaching
the transparent history okay people
people banning books uh no not not
talking about these are the books being
banned
those are not the only books being
banned right they're they're
talking about banning books on rosa
parks biography out of schools not
talking about slavery not talking about
you know oppression and things like that
they're calling that critical race
theory thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you